CA: I mean, Gary Kasparov said on the first day [of TED2017]
that the winners of chess, surprisingly, turned out to be two amateur chess players
with three mediocre-ish, mediocre-to-good, computer programs,
that could outperform one grand master with one great chess player,
like it was all part of the process.
And it almost seems like you're talking about a much richer version
of that same idea.
ST: Yeah, I mean, as you followed the fantastic panels yesterday morning,
two sessions about AI,
robotic overlords and the human response,
many, many great things were said.
But one of the concerns is that we sometimes confuse
what's actually been done with AI with this kind of overlord threat,
where your AI develops consciousness, right?
The last thing I want is for my AI to have consciousness.
I don't want to come into my kitchen
and have the refrigerator fall in love with the dishwasher
and tell me, because I wasn't nice enough,
my food is now warm.
I wouldn't buy these products, and I don't want them.
But the truth is, for me,
AI has always been an augmentation of people.
It's been an augmentation of us,
to make us stronger.
And I think Kasparov was exactly correct.
It's been the combination of human smarts and machine smarts
that make us stronger.
The theme of machines making us stronger is as old as machines are.
The agricultural revolution took place because it made steam engines
and farming equipment that couldn't farm by itself,
that never replaced us; it made us stronger.
And I believe this new wave of AI will make us much, much stronger
as a human race.
CA: We'll come on to that a bit more,
but just to continue with the scary part of this for some people,
like, what feels like it gets scary for people is when you have
a computer that can, one, rewrite its own code,
so, it can create multiple copies of itself,
try a bunch of different code versions,
possibly even at random,
and then check them out and see if a goal is achieved and improved.
So, say the goal is to do better on an intelligence test.
You know, a computer that's moderately good at that,
you could try a million versions of that.
You might find one that was better,
and then, you know, repeat.
And so the concern is that you get some sort of runaway effect
where everything is fine on Thursday evening,
and you come back into the lab on Friday morning,
and because of the speed of computers and so forth,
things have gone crazy, and suddenly --
ST: I would say this is a possibility,
but it's a very remote possibility.
So let me just translate what I heard you say.
In the AlphaGo case, we had exactly this thing:
the computer would play the game against itself
and then learn new rules.
And what machine learning is is a rewriting of the rules.
It's the rewriting of code.
But I think there was absolutely no concern
that AlphaGo would take over the world.
It can't even play chess.
CA: No, no, no, but now, these are all very single-domain things.
But it's possible to imagine.
I mean, we just saw a computer that seemed nearly capable
of passing a university entrance test,
that can kind of -- it can't read and understand in the sense that we can,
but it can certainly absorb all the text
and maybe see increased patterns of meaning.
Isn't there a chance that, as this broadens out,
there could be a different kind of runaway effect?
ST: That's where I draw the line, honestly.
And the chance exists -- I don't want to downplay it --
but I think it's remote, and it's not the thing that's on my mind these days,
because I think the big revolution is something else.
Everything successful in AI to the present date
has been extremely specialized,
and it's been thriving on a single idea,
which is massive amounts of data.
The reason AlphaGo works so well is because of massive numbers of Go plays,
and AlphaGo can't drive a car or fly a plane.
The Google self-driving car or the Udacity self-driving car
thrives on massive amounts of data, and it can't do anything else.
It can't even control a motorcycle.
It's a very specific, domain-specific function,
and the same is true for our cancer app.
There has been almost no progress on this thing called "general AI,"
where you go to an AI and say, "Hey, invent for me special relativity
or string theory."
It's totally in the infancy.
The reason I want to emphasize this,
I see the concerns, and I want to acknowledge them.
But if I were to think about one thing,
I would ask myself the question, "What if we can take anything repetitive
and make ourselves 100 times as efficient?"
It so turns out, 300 years ago, we all worked in agriculture
and did farming and did repetitive things.
Today, 75 percent of us work in offices
and do repetitive things.
We've become spreadsheet monkeys.
And not just low-end labor.
We've become dermatologists doing repetitive things,
lawyers doing repetitive things.
I think we are at the brink of being able to take an AI,
look over our shoulders,
and they make us maybe 10 or 50 times as effective in these repetitive things.
That's what is on my mind.
CA: That sounds super exciting.
The process of getting there seems a little terrifying to some people,
because once a computer can do this repetitive thing
much better than the dermatologist
or than the driver, especially, is the thing that's talked about
so much now,
suddenly millions of jobs go,
and, you know, the country's in revolution
before we ever get to the more glorious aspects of what's possible.
ST: Yeah, and that's an issue, and it's a big issue,
and it was pointed out yesterday morning by several guest speakers.
Now, prior to me showing up onstage,
I confessed I'm a positive, optimistic person,
so let me give you an optimistic pitch,
which is, think of yourself back 300 years ago.
Europe just survived 140 years of continuous war,
none of you could read or write,
there were no jobs that you hold today,
like investment banker or software engineer or TV anchor.
We would all be in the fields and farming.
Now here comes little Sebastian with a little steam engine in his pocket,
saying, "Hey guys, look at this.
It's going to make you 100 times as strong, so you can do something else."
And then back in the day, there was no real stage,
but Chris and I hang out with the cows in the stable,
and he says, "I'm really concerned about it,
because I milk my cow every day, and what if the machine does this for me?"
The reason why I mention this is,
we're always good in acknowledging past progress and the benefit of it,
like our iPhones or our planes or electricity or medical supply.
We all love to live to 80, which was impossible 300 years ago.
But we kind of don't apply the same rules to the future.
So if I look at my own job as a CEO,
I would say 90 percent of my work is repetitive,
I don't enjoy it,
I spend about four hours per day on stupid, repetitive email.
And I'm burning to have something that helps me get rid of this.
Why?
Because I believe all of us are insanely creative;
I think the TED community more than anybody else.
But even blue-collar workers; I think you can go to your hotel maid
and have a drink with him or her,
and an hour later, you find a creative idea.
What this will empower is to turn this creativity into action.
Like, what if you could build Google in a day?
What if you could sit over beer and invent the next Snapchat,
whatever it is,
and tomorrow morning it's up and running?
And that is not science fiction.
What's going to happen is,
we are already in history.
We've unleashed this amazing creativity
by de-slaving us from farming
and later, of course, from factory work
and have invented so many things.
It's going to be even better, in my opinion.
And there's going to be great side effects.
One of the side effects will be
that things like food and medical supply and education and shelter
and transportation
will all become much more affordable to all of us,
not just the rich people.
CA: Hmm.
So when Martin Ford argued, you know, that this time it's different
because the intelligence that we've used in the past
to find new ways to be
will be matched at the same pace
by computers taking over those things,
what I hear you saying is that, not completely,
because of human creativity.
Do you think that that's fundamentally different from the kind of creativity
that computers can do?
ST: So, that's my firm belief as an AI person --
that I haven't seen any real progress on creativity
and out-of-the-box thinking.
What I see right now -- and this is really important for people to realize,
because the word "artificial intelligence" is so threatening,
and then we have Steve Spielberg tossing a movie in,
where all of a sudden the computer is our overlord,
but it's really a technology.
It's a technology that helps us do repetitive things.
And the progress has been entirely on the repetitive end.
It's been in legal document discovery.
It's been contract drafting.
It's been screening X-rays of your chest.
And these things are so specialized,
I don't see the big threat of humanity.
In fact, we as people --
I mean, let's face it: we've become superhuman.
We've made us superhuman.
We can swim across the Atlantic in 11 hours.
We can take a device out of our pocket
and shout all the way to Australia,
and in real time, have that person shouting back to us.
That's physically not possible. We're breaking the rules of physics.
When this is said and done, we're going to remember everything
we've ever said and seen,
you'll remember every person,
which is good for me in my early stages of Alzheimer's.
Sorry, what was I saying? I forgot.
CA: (Laughs)
ST: We will probably have an IQ of 1,000 or more.
There will be no more spelling classes for our kids,
because there's no spelling issue anymore.
There's no math issue anymore.
And I think what really will happen is that we can be super creative.
And we are. We are creative.
That's our secret weapon.
CA: So the jobs that are getting lost,
in a way, even though it's going to be painful,
humans are capable of more than those jobs.
This is the dream.
The dream is that humans can rise to just a new level of empowerment
and discovery.
That's the dream.
ST: And think about this:
if you look at the history of humanity,
that might be whatever -- 60-100,000 years old, give or take --
almost everything that you cherish in terms of invention,
of technology, of things we've built,
has been invented in the last 150 years.
If you toss in the book and the wheel, it's a little bit older.
Or the axe.
But your phone, your sneakers,
these chairs, modern manufacturing, penicillin --
the things we cherish.
Now, that to me means
the next 150 years will find more things.
In fact, the pace of invention has gone up, not gone down, in my opinion.
I believe only one percent of interesting things have been invented yet. Right?
We haven't cured cancer.
We don't have flying cars -- yet. Hopefully, I'll change this.
That used to be an example people laughed about. (Laughs)
It's funny, isn't it? Working secretly on flying cars.
We don't live twice as long yet. OK?
We don't have this magic implant in our brain
that gives us the information we want.
And you might be appalled by it,
but I promise you, once you have it, you'll love it.
I hope you will.
It's a bit scary, I know.
There are so many things we haven't invented yet
that I think we'll invent.
We have no gravity shields.
We can't beam ourselves from one location to another.
That sounds ridiculous,
but about 200 years ago,
experts were of the opinion that flight wouldn't exist,
even 120 years ago,
and if you moved faster than you could run,
you would instantly die.
So who says we are correct today that you can't beam a person
from here to Mars?
CA: Sebastian, thank you so much
for your incredibly inspiring vision and your brilliance.
Thank you, Sebastian Thrun.
That was fantastic. (Applause)